[Music]
in lock me up news and throw away the
[ __ ] key
sounds like an S&M submitted by quick
mass what to do a con man asked for 20
years in solitary confinement because he
can't stop conning people that's another
con oh sure you can't give him what he
wants he's gonna con you again that
solitary confinement though yeah I was
gonna con him there himself did you not
see what's that [ __ ] movie the
cannibal citizen no no the citizen jumbo
with Gerard Butler yes there you go
when he goes to the steak house and he
get the [ __ ] bone-in ribeye and he
stabs yeah yeah yeah that one that's
what he wanted solitary confinement that
was my favorite part of the [ __ ]
movie because he got to eat whatever he
wanted as his last meal yeah I went to
that steak house in Vegas not that good
what was it
I forgot the name but it's the same
steak house oh the steak look bomb it
was like for the movie it was good but I
would have recommend it yeah so this guy
his name is Jimmy Sabatino he's a potato
Jimmy so Deena yeah he's one of
Florida's most notorious and prolific
con men so he was recently convicted to
20 years of solitary confinement after
pleading guilty to running a ten point
four million dollar fraud Wow what was
the fraud so his most recent con was
where he convinced two correction
officers at the detention center where
he was staying to smuggle five
cellphones for him and that's what he
would use to call his victims and his
associates on the outside cuz he had
other people helping him so he was
caught in from the inside yeah what the
Mexican Mafia you know all the freakin
calls happen from inside of the prison
and then they control the gang from
inside the fat es so how do you say
prison in your language
la princesa Garson
like incarceration I don't know okay I
used the wrong terminology prison
Spanish Mikasa yes you use those
cellphones and he would be posed him and
his associates would pose as Sony and
rock nation executives they would reach
out to luxury store managers and they
would send emails as well aimed at
convincing them to let them borrow
jewelry watches and other goods for
music videos and other advertising god
yeah and so he would get these items but
obviously instead of returning them they
would be selling them in pawn shops or
they would just keep it for themselves
and then they would also send money into
Sabatino x' prison commissary account
how much did he make off of this it was
ten point four million sorry I was a pig
attention and good and accommodation in
luxury hotels the reason why I was
trying to figure out the actual number
is because that's really impressive to
make ten point four million while in
prison yeah because it's already hard to
make that much outside of prison it's so
interesting because I don't care about
jewelry jewelry does nothing for me you
know what I mean
like when I see somebody with a bling
and ask some [ __ ] [ __ ] on that I'm
like that looks heavy that's all I think
I don't I don't envy it you know what I
mean I like the rapper's yeah you know
I've seen the light y'all you see this
[ __ ] right here that's cool you look
stupid when I was 16 and I saw everybody
with a diamond-encrusted g-shock I
thought that was the coolest thing on
earth because Missy Elliott had it and
she was like in a music video and I was
like oh that's different because I like
g-shock and I thought diamonds were
pretty cool back then because all the
rapper's talked about it I'm like never
envious of this should this should it's
all stupid I was so that's what you
liked and probably around the same age I
wanted diamonds in my teeth
oh really you did like girls no no no
like literally in my teeth all I did put
the embed right good yeah like one so
that when I smiled want to be some kind
of villain no I just wanted when I
smiled it was like ding I remember that
being a trend so all the people that
have diamonds are teeth now they have a
hole there probably
I'm Jung bro I'm not thinking how old
are you uh maybe like in junior high
I'm 16 thank God they never close I know
I've never gotten to Julie either yeah
like for me I think I like watches and
stuff but then like like let's say this
is the watch that I like that versus
something more they like bling at the
[ __ ] out I still just like that watch
because it's the watch the only thing I
really wanted was like a gold necklace
with a cross on it because a bunch of my
Vietnamese homies you said it no but I
always wanted a Buddha necklace too yeah
because we all had shade yeah because
they had it I always had one I've ever
wanted to wear so I thought I'd look so
asian lunch it looks so Fabi you had a
Buddha I had a bunch like Buddha like
little Jade necklaces by never won any
of them because I just look so funny you
even have that Jade bracelet your mom
that's I'm a ton of like jade jewelry
that my parents gave me I've always
liked it but my tastes changed so it
just changes over the years you know
like there was a phase where I like that
bling [ __ ] but I could never afford it
so I got like cubics and I had fat
cubics a my my ear and [ __ ] and I was
like you know those Jade bracelets they
put them on when they're younger and
then they grow into it is that what they
do there's like different sizes people
that do that because my friend couldn't
take hers off yeah I just like that cuz
she snipped it all like a [ __ ] ring
that's why huge and you wear it up here
yeah a lot of people do that like they
put her on the baby and the baby grows
into it and it just stays with you under
develop you yes she was like she was
like in junior high and then she still
hasn't now but it's it's not loose it's
just like they're like what if we got
one for Tiger right now and he turns out
to be a [ __ ] monster I mean if they
like break it off yeah I don't I guess
to start all over again but I don't know
but she's like it's like glass it's like
glass yeah I think like jewellery is
really pretty but I think for me I just
don't find it really practical to wear
everyday cuz I feel like it gets in the
way of everything like that's cuz you're
a working girl wheezes but imagine if
you are
I appreciate it I love it I think it
looks great on people but I just feel
like it's not for me but I honestly have
Casey's family didn't give me his
bracelet I wouldn't I would never wear
like I'd see I think that's very it's
pretty you know what I'm saying
but I've never looked at somebody else's
jewelry be like sobs I heard good thing
like it always gets in the way like
sometimes like I'm washing my hands gets
all wet I like it more other people than
on me yeah
people well my that's pretty dope that
stuff that stuff I can't see myself
going like I wish I had it like what
Dave is saying if I wasn't lifting or if
I wasn't training at all I'd have rings
everywhere me too I'd be [ __ ] stats I
would for sure I mean you see me wear
like like multiple necklace like the
[ __ ] Thai girls yeah I'd be stacked
all there infinity stacks you know I
always buy jewelry telling myself I'm
gonna wear this me to have so much joy
anything never wear I want more but I
get tired I went through a phase though
remember I have my [ __ ] room stall
rings and all that you've your bracelet
yeah but it's hard because like you got
to look a certain way to match certain
jewelry mm-hmm and then it doesn't match
not get angry because if I see myself
and it doesn't work the same way that I
wanted to I'm like this Joey's wrong not
me and the color too like I love rose
gold but it blends with my skin too much
so rose gold doesn't look too good with
my skin you know but have you ever got
mad at yourself because it doesn't match
with what you think like I get mad at
myself because in the morning I know I'm
[ __ ] ripped right and then I'm not no
I don't say yeah I'm like what the [ __ ]
I know my shoulders bigger than that you
like what is it happening and I get
messy mara is broken yeah this is wrong
the lighting yeah yeah this is wrong
this goes to show you like the fine line
of like business and [ __ ] cuz if you
would have just like didn't did a [ __ ]
just a little bit more legally he would
have killed it in the game like if you
actually it wasn't manager agent like if
it was Noel to pull the same connection
yeah cuz he's doing but he wasn't that
made ten point four million dollars you
probably only made 500,000 what's the
picture he would have been slower but
he's a
great business but 10.40 he also went
out to be in 20 years now I feel like
con artists though they get the thrill
it's fun and because he can and get the
way with yeah I think so they take pride
and being a lying sack of [ __ ] yeah I'm
gonna show you guys hold up really quick
on hammock training what you would do
Jimmy where is it air his eyes like that
for real
or you just didn't want to look into the
camera legit okay you know he's actually
right now he's in the supermax prison
why which is like crazy cuz he works for
the mob and all that stuff too well cuz
he's one of like the most want to areas
prolific con men okay that's a very big
achievement
I thought Mexican maximum-security
prison Mexican security maximum maximum
security prisons work for like dangerous
people like physically dangerous yeah
cuz the Unabomber is that the same
prison and the Boston Marathon bomber
bomber are also a bit cuz it could be
he's just such a cunning guy yeah like
it's like if you if you put any normal
person next time he'll be able to just
tap into people's minds and [ __ ]
officers he convinced them and he was
there for like a week or some [ __ ] yeah
I don't condone crime but sometimes it's
nice to learn like positive things from
people that's achieved greatness
if only he just made his ten million and
he stopped but he just had to keep on
doing what he was doing cuz he was
addicted he's just like a Walter White
yeah that's like he wants to be in
solitary confinement cuz he says I he's
near anyone he's gonna call him he's
like listen guys I love to lie and I
love to con so don't put me around human
beings cuz I'll condemn ya and the judge
was like okay judges stupid I could see
through his [ __ ] plans his plan was a
bunch of [ __ ] he stirred in his butthole
and they's gonna be in solitary
confinement gonna pull all that stuff
out and then he's gonna continue doing
business and he's gonna [ __ ] around the
world like double time okay now there's
no officers bothering no they could what
they're watching heaven hope there's
yeah not in the prison in my head
confinements I'll leave you alone yeah
there's just the hole here is your
interview what is most reliable targets
have always been hotel pound it it's not
as complicated as one might think
it was the reservation manage will
receive a phone call the conversation
tonight something along the lines of
also from Sony Music I have a party
coming into Miami uh we're gonna need
the reserved X amount of notice that we
then send a confirmation email to the
hotel's Finance Department pretending to
be Sony's VP of Finance James Harvey in
the case of all the hotels in Miami
Beach was from a gmail account here is
one of those emails we are requesting
the direct billing of all charges that
is room tax and all incidentals the
hilton wrote back eagerly thank you for
the opportunity
took forging our parents signature to
the next level such a accomplished
person he even managed to fix his lazy
eye at the government's expense because
he convinced correctional officials that
he had a stroke and that he'd got a lazy
eye let me fix it for him I wish I could
lie like this mother [ __ ] I can't do
it he would be a great youtuber a lot of
them are a lot of icons audio yeah
[ __ ] fake pranks fake social
experiments fake drama
they brought they fake problems and
fight with other youtubers they [ __ ]
orchestrate that [ __ ] so much fake fake
fake fake I can't do it
I [ __ ] murder myself even prettier
Zelda
[Music]
[Music]